Salut, on est mercredi. Aujourd'hui pour cette nouvelle astuce
je vous emmène en Inde. Chez les Sioux ?
Nan! Chez les Indous. Qu'est ce qu'on va faire en Inde ?
C'est ça la question que vous vous posez
On va faire simplement des mathématiques
des petites multiplications tu vas m'en donner des nouvelles
Pour l'astuce du mercredi, j'avais simplement envie de vous parler des multiplications védiques
Les multiplications védiques qu'est ce que c'est ?
Ce sont les Indiens qui ont inventés cette méthode
parce qu'il faut quand même savoir que les Indiens et quand je dis les Indiens
je dis les Indous bien sur ! Je parle pas de ceux qui sont dans leur tipi
Les Indiens ont tout simplement créé le système numérique actuel
avec les chiffres de 1 à 9 et c'est même eux qui ont créé le 0
ça parait rien d'avoir créé le 0, mais c'est énorme, c'est énorme ! Parce qu'ils ont réussi à symboliser le rien
et ça, ça a ouvert des portes à pleins de choses, mais on s'en reparlera
si ça vous intéresse, et si ça vous intéresse pas, j'en reparlerai pas
Ils ont précisé les mathématiques telles qu'on les connaît aujourd'hui
Ils ont fait plein de choses pour nous dont une chose un peu oubliée
les multiplications védiques
vous en avez peut être déjà vu, aujourd'hui je vais vous expliquer comment les faire
ce sont les multiplications que l'on fait en dessinant
on ne calcule plus, on dessine
Il y a 2 types de multiplications védiques. Celles qu'on dessine
et une autre méthode, qui consiste à poser le calcul
Je vous en reparlerai peut être dans un des master class du samedi
mais là on va parler de la version la plus ludique
Celle qui consiste à dessiner des traits pour symboliser les deux chiffres de la multiplication
si je veux faire 2 fois 12
alors je vais dessiner 2 traits pour symboliser le 2
et pour dessiner le 12 je vais faire un trait pour le 1
et un peu plus bas, je vais descendre un peu, je vais faire 2 traits pour le 2
je crois que c'est clair !
pour trouver le résultat je vais créer des secteurs et compter le nombre de croisements
ça c'est un secteur
et ça c'est un autre secteur
Le premier secteur il comporte 2 croisements
donc je vais commencer à écrire un 2 ici. J'ai 4 croisements dans mon deuxième secteur
donc ça me fais un 4
et 2 fois 12 ça fait bien 24 et je sais que vous le saviez
Il n'y a aucun problème avec ça. Essayons maintenant plus compliqué avec 13 fois 21
attention... Apparition
13 fois 21 ça va être un bon exemple pour vous expliquer
comment on fait avec des nombres à 2 chiffres
donc mon 13 je vais le dessiner comme ça
je vais faire 1 trait pour le 1
3 traits pour le 3
et mon 21 je le dessine perpendiculairement par rapport à mon premier nombre
donc les 2 ici pour le 2 de 21
et 1 ici pour 21
à chaque fois, vous devez placer le deuxième nombre perpendiculairement
dans vos tracés de ligne sinon y a pas de croisement, forcément
j'identifie les secteurs, c'est par les diagonales, là j'en ai un ici
là j'en ai un ici
et là j'en ai un ici
maintenant j'ai plus qu'à compter le nombre de croisements qu'il y a par secteur
Il y a une seule règle à respecter, il faut partir du bas vers le haut
du dernier chiffre au premier, comme ça si il y a une retenue, elle va s’intégrer automatiquement
je pars du bas: 1, 2, 3, donc ça finira par un 3
celui du milieu: 1,2,3,4,5,6 et 1, 7, voila ici
et en haut : 2, donc 13 fois 21 ça fait bien 273
je vous en fais un autre, un peu plus compliqué pour vraiment que vous puissiez bien comprendre
on va dire 34 fois 42
je mets ça je sais même pas si j'aurai assez de place pour que ce soit bien clair
là ça commence à être sympa
là je les entoure pour vous les faire voir mais après quand on le fais soi même
on a même plus besoin de les entourer
deuxième secteur, ça va être celui ci
et enfin troisième secteur, qui va être celui là
c'est un peu fouillis sur ma petite ardoise
je  compte du bas vers le haut donc le bas : 1,2,3,4,5,6,7,8
je mets mon 8, ensuite au milieu: 1,2,3,4,5,6,7,8,9,10,11,12,13,14,15,16,17,18,19,20,21,22
donc je mets mon 2 ici et moi je retiens 2 pour le secteur suivant
comme ça je vais commencer par compter: 1,2,3,4,5,6,7,8,9,10,11,12,13,14
et je rajoute mon 14
ça c’était vraiment pour vous faire voir  l'importance de compter du bas vers le haut
comme ça vous allez injecter au retenue, comme ça dans les bulles directement
moi je les note au dessus, je sais pas comment font les autres mais je note ma retenue au dessus de la bulle correspondante
ça marche évidemment avec tout les nombres
vous pouvez multipliez des nombres à 3 chiffres par des nombre à 2 chiffres
vous faites ce que vous voulez, c'est toujours la même méthodes, il suffit de dessiner
de bien entourer ces secteurs, pour commencer ça permet de pas se perdre
et de prendre le temps de compter après, avec son doigts en fait, y a plus de calcul à faire
c'est que du comptage en réalité
un petit dernier pour la route, disons 253 fois 5
vous avez bien compris qu'à chaque fois j’espace entre chaque chiffres, là j'ai 253 d'écrit
bon là y a aucune difficulté à trouver les secteurs
donc sur le premier on a:1,2,3,4,5,6,7,8,9,10,11,12,13,14,15
5 et j'avais une retenue de 1 dans le secteur d'après
1,2,3,4,5 cinq ok et un 26 et j'ai 2 dans ce secteur là
1,2,3,4,5,6,7,8,9,10,11,12
253 fois 5 ça fait bien 1265
et là vous comprenez en quoi la méthode elle est ouf, c'est que maintenant y a plus à calculer
y a simplement à compter, y a juste à visualiser, et à compter comme ça avec son doigts
c'est très intéressant pour les adultes, c'est aussi intéressant pour les enfants de leur apprendre ça
dans certains pays, je crois qu'on leur apprend maintenant
en tout cas, je sais qu'il y a une école chinoise qui a une méthodologie maintenant qui utilise les multiplications védiques
partagez cette vidéo, ça peut servir à pleins pleins de monde, c'est l'astuce du mercredi
pour le mental vlog, abonnez vous à la chaine
abonnez vous, je vous signale quand même qu'on s'approche de l'objectif 2500
à 2500 abonnés on se retrouvera en live, par caméra interposée
on va pouvoir parler directement, peut être faire des mentalisations, parler des astuces
parlez de tous ça sur le mentalisme, donc faites tourner cette vidéo
abonnez vous à la chaine et rendez vous demain à 17h pour le prochain mental vlog
tchao !